[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: And you are
all here, very wisely,
to meet the amazing
Gail Simmons.
[APPLAUSE]
GAIL SIMMONS: I'll
just come out.
I'm like standing in the corner.
I don't really know why.
Hi, guys.
SPEAKER: Welcome.
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So maybe you
know Gail from "Top Chef."
Maybe you've read
her lovely book.
But today she's here to talk
to us about her new cookbook.
So tell us, what's the deal?
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you.
Thank you guys for having me.
It's my first time at
Google on the West Coast.
SPEAKER: Welcome!
GAIL SIMMONS: It's
pretty awesome.
I know, wow.
[APPLAUSE]
You make a good reason
for moving to the left.
Anyway, last week I
launched my first cookbook.
I took about five
years to work up
the courage to make it
and two years to write it.
It is definitely
a labor of love.
You all have it in your hands.
It's a very personal book.
"Bringing it Home" started
in several notebooks--
I don't know-- 15 years ago.
Stories, recipes, flavors,
dishes that I would write down
from my travels.
And for years I thought,
well, who else would ever
want to look at these but me?
And finally, about a
little over two years
ago, I decided to put them
all together in one volume
and share them with the world.
So they're brand new,
and they're very special.
The background of
the book itself
is that I have really--
well, obviously
spent my whole life eating.
But my mother was
actually a cooking teacher
and my father was a great
adventurer and traveler.
He was born in South Africa.
And we spent a lot of our
lives traveling back and forth
between here and South Africa.
Here, actually, is
not here at all.
But I grew up in
Toronto, Canada--
so pretty, actually, far from
here with not as much sunshine.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER: We don't have to
be too technical about it.
But "here."
GAIL SIMMONS: Sure,
but North America.
Certainly.
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
I've been working
in the food industry
for 20 years in a bunch
of different capacities.
I started out as an
assistant editor.
I knew I wanted to
write about food
and so went to
culinary school, worked
as a cook in some of
the greatest, toughest
kitchens in New York.
Not advisable, necessarily,
but an extraordinary education.
SPEAKER: And an
adventure, right?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes,
and absolutely
an adventure-- an eye-opening,
extraordinary exploration
of food, and an amazing
time to live in New York.
And then from there, went to
work for an incredible food
writer as his recipe
and research assistant.
And then I worked for
a Chef Daniel Boulud
for three years in marketing
and public relations.
And in 2004, I took a job
at "Food & Wine" Magazine--
actually, originally,
directing part
of the marketing department.
And soon that transitioned
and split into two jobs
without me realizing that
either would actually happen.
I took over the direction
of the "Food & Wine" Classic
in Aspen, which
is "Food & Wine's"
biggest event of the year.
SPEAKER: So fun.
Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: The most fun and
most beautiful place on earth.
And then, simultaneously,
Bravo called "Food & Wine"
and asked if they would partner
on a risk they were taking
for the network-- a new
show about the real life
of competitive cooks.
SPEAKER: I don't
think it worked out.
GAIL SIMMONS: I
know, I can't believe
I actually accepted the job.
SPEAKER: So risky of you.
GAIL SIMMONS: I know.
I mean, at the
time, it really was.
I have to say that when
my publisher came to me
and said that they had
this idea for a show
and that Bravo wanted to
partner with us on a reality
show about real,
professional cooks--
competitive reality show--
I was completely squeamish.
SPEAKER: At the time, it
was definitely a new idea.
GAIL SIMMONS: I
mean, this was 2005.
SPEAKER: Yeah, it
was a long time ago.
GAIL SIMMONS: So my point of
reference for competition shows
at the time were--
SPEAKER: "Survivor"
GAIL SIMMONS: "Real World,"
"Survivor," "Fear Factor."
SPEAKER: It's a combination
of those three, I think,
if you really think about it.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
what it was, exactly--
with a lot of perishable
goods, knives, and fire.
I was like, bad, bad.
Don't do it.
SPEAKER: And chef temperaments.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes.
But it was my job, so
I took it regardless.
And we actually flew
to San Francisco
and shot our first
season in San Francisco
right around this time 2005
so exactly 12 years ago.
SPEAKER: Wow, gosh.
GAIL SIMMONS: I was 7.
SPEAKER: I was, too.
GAIL SIMMONS: I was a prodigy.
I was the Doogie Howser of--
[LAUGHTER]
--yeah,w of the food world.
And we've been
doing it ever since.
We've made 15
seasons, 5 spin-offs,
been nominated for 11 Emmys--
one of which we actually won.
SPEAKER: Yeah, you did!
[APPLAUSE]
GAIL SIMMONS: Which we
really could have never--
I mean, thank you.
Thank you.
That wasn't so much a
pat on the back as it
was the fact that we were--
and still are-- we
think of ourselves,
in our category, as The
Little Engine that Could.
We are a small cable
show of a bunch
of food nerds having
a real conversation
about professional kitchens.
And we shot our 15th season
in Colorado a few months ago,
and it premieres in
December, which is awesome.
SPEAKER: Can't wait.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's
really beautiful.
SPEAKER: Can't wait.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
obviously, it's allowed me--
back to the book-- a
lot of time to travel.
We shoot every season
in a different city,
in a different country.
And my job with "Food
& Wine" continues,
so I spend a lot of time
traveling and on the road.
And so this book
is a combination
of recipes and discoveries
and lessons learned along
my adventures traveling for
work, cooking with chefs,
spending a lot of
time on flight delays
with some of the greatest
chefs in the world,
sitting at judges'
table with them
and discovering little roadside
street stalls from Colorado
to the Cayman Islands
to Singapore, Indonesia,
and Japan.
And so it's been a
wild ride, and I've
had to eat a lot of food.
But most of all,
the best thing of it
is that I take all of
these ideas home with me.
And so this book is very
much a home cookbook.
It is not about tweezers
and chefy-chef terms.
And I think that every recipe,
although based in the familiar,
really has a lesson or a tip
or a flavor combination that'll
make you a better cook
in your own, real life.
SPEAKER: So excited
to try it out.
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: What are you
going to make today?
GAIL SIMMONS: So I'm going to
make two dishes which I thought
would be great for
lunch-- healthy, fresh,
and both of them very simple.
The first one is a grilled
radicchio and lentil salad,
and the second is a rustic fish
soup with fennel and orange.
And both are really
great this time of year,
very seasonal in terms
of their ingredients.
Hardy, but super
healthy and fresh.
SPEAKER: Well, let's do it.
GAIL SIMMONS: You want to cook?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
GAIL SIMMONS: You guys in?
SPEAKER: Let's go.
GAIL SIMMONS: Also feel free,
by the way, to talk to me.
I don't eat people.
And I just want to
make sure that I
know how to turn on the stove.
I do-- look at that.
SPEAKER: I, notoriously, do not.
So if you've been
to talk with me in--
the one in Mountain View
is really confusing, and--
GAIL SIMMONS: These are
induction, right, by the way?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: So, right--
I'm going to make you work.
SPEAKER: I just
stand here and talk.
Of course, happy
to help, always.
GAIL SIMMONS: So the first thing
I'm doing is making my lentils.
The lentils I'm using--
I'm using green lentils.
But obviously, you can
use any lentil you want.
And you can certainly flavor
them in different ways.
The most important
thing about lentils is--
don't overcook them.
So I'm going to start with
about 5 cups of water.
I'm adding some bay leaves
and some garlic cloves
to the water.
And I'm going to
bring it to a boil.
I'm just going to
squish the garlic cloves
a little bit so that all those
delicious oils and flavor comes
through.
Drop them right in.
You know what I need from
you guys, if you don't mind?
A kitchen towel--
forgot to grab.
Are there here?
SPEAKER: Here, right here.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, perfect.
Great, thank you, because
now I have garlic juice
all over my hands.
I'm going to bring
that to a boil.
Then I'm going to salt the
water and add my lentils.
The thing about salting, which
people talk about all the time,
is most people
would add the salt--
or think to add the
salt-- right now.
Season your water.
You always want to season
your water-- whether you're
cooking beans, legumes, pasta.
Seasoning is obviously
something that you
hear us talk about ad
nauseam on "Top Chef"
and in any cook's life.
But a little trick that
I've learned over the years
is you don't want to
salt the water right now.
You actually want
to salt it right
before you put whatever
it is into the pot.
So that will drop the
temperature slightly,
but then it comes back
to a boil very quickly,
and that's when you add
the pasta or the lentils
or whatever you're putting in.
Over time, if you salt
your water too early,
it will pit the pot.
Salt is corrosive.
So I like to, now,
get in the habit--
when I remember-- to actually
wait till the water comes
to a boil to salt it.
And it's going to take a minute.
So we'll wait.
And in the meantime,
I'm going to start
two pieces of the salad.
One is the vegetables
that will get grilled.
And two is the salad
dressing itself.
And the good thing
about salad dressing
is that it can be
made in advance
and it can be made
in big batches.
I'm making literally
the simplest salad
dressing of all time.
And it's a salad dressing
that has a lot of flavor.
And you don't have to
worry about ratios so much.
And you can make it
times 5, times 10.
Keep it in a jar.
I like to keep it in a sealed
Mason jar in my fridge.
And then you just give it a
shake and you always have it.
And it's so much better than
buying store-bought dressing.
There are certain
reasons and times
to buy a store-bought
dressing, granted,
but there's a lot of added
salt and preservatives
that none of us really need.
So I'm a big advocate of
just making it yourself,
which is really easy to do.
I'm going to start with some
lemon juice and some red wine--
or sherry vinegar,
whatever you have at home.
And mix those together.
Most classic dressings call
for about a 50-50 ratio
oil to vinegar.
I'm an acid person.
That sounds weird.
SPEAKER: Culinarily speaking.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes.
I like acid in my food.
So I tend to actually put
a little more than that.
But first little trick for you--
I'm putting some chopped
shallots in here,
and I'm going to give
that a bit of a whisk.
And then I'm going to
let them sit in the acid
before I add my
seasoning and my oil.
If you let them sit for five
minutes or so, they'll soften.
And that strength--
the astringency--
SPEAKER: Sharpness?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, sharpness--
SPEAKER: Comes out
of it a little bit?
GAIL SIMMONS: --of any onion.
But in the shallots,
which are great in salads,
you want the flavor
of them, but you don't
want that intense onioniness.
So if you let them sit in
the acid for a few minutes
before you make the dressing,
then they're good to go.
How's my water doing?
SPEAKER: It's getting there.
GAIL SIMMONS: Great.
I'm going to oil--
SPEAKER: It's a technical term.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah,
it's getting there.
GAIL SIMMONS:
That's what happens.
I feel like it's
going to be fast.
You can tell.
SPEAKER: I think so,
it's coming together.
GAIL SIMMONS: This is a
state-of-the-art teaching
kitchen, by the way.
I'm very honored to be the first
guest in this kitchen, that's
kind of crazy.
SPEAKER: Oh, we could
not be happier about it.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's amazing.
SPEAKER: We took some good
learnings from our original
and changed some things around.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
what it's about.
SPEAKER: You know, we launch and
iterate here at Google, right?
Iterating on the
teaching kitchen model.
GAIL SIMMONS: I imagine
that's some sort of insider,
yes, we do.
I get it.
SPEAKER: Maybe a little bit.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm learning a
lot while I'm here, by the way.
OK, so I'm just oiling
the grate a little bit.
And then I'm going to
lightly grill a few things.
You guys, I don't know
if you can see me.
I can't really see what
you're looking at there.
What do you need?
What do you want to move?
SPEAKER: She's just
clearing the path.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh,
yeah, go for it.
OK.
SPEAKER: They can kind of--
right on the--
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, I
see what's happening.
Well, that's where
I'm going to be.
SPEAKER: And now, look.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, wow,
the magic of television!
SPEAKER: We're so fancy!
GAIL SIMMONS: That's right.
So I'm going to
slice an onion up.
When you're-- this
might seem basic,
but when you're
cutting an onion,
don't ever cut off
this end, the root end.
Cut off this tip and
then peel from here.
If you cut off the
root, the whole thing
will sort of fall apart on you.
And it's easier to
just peel it like this
before you take off
that root and cut it
and leave the root at the end.
SPEAKER: That's a good one.
I don't even think
of that, really.
GAIL SIMMONS: Well, a lot--
there's different schools.
Some people don't
care as much as me,
but I just find it easier.
Because then, all
of a sudden, you're
dealing with the clumsy
rings and everything
is falling apart.
And it's a lot easier--
especially for this recipe,
because I'm going to be grilling
the onion in big slices--
to keep the whole thing intact.
SPEAKER: Sure, keep
it more intact, yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: And there's
kind of big grates
that I don't want
it to fall into.
And I don't really want to
start a fire as the first person
in this kitchen.
SPEAKER: We have a
really good hood system.
Everyone is very safe.
GAIL SIMMONS: Great.
I'm sure there's
an exit strategy.
We're going to be fine.
AUDIENCE: So would you cut off
the root if you were dicing it?
SPEAKER: Would you cut off the
root if you were dicing it?
GAIL SIMMONS: If I were
to dice this onion,
I would cut it in half so
that I have a flat surface.
Because you always
kind of-- life
is easier with a flat surface.
Can I grab a bowl
for food waste?
Anything.
I would cut it in
half like this.
Put one half on the flat
surface and diced it.
And then slice the other half.
Again, to keep this intact.
If I cut this off and then cut
it in half, all the petals,
all the levels would fall apart.
Now for the sake of grilling
it the way I want to grill it,
we're getting there.
SPEAKER: We are.
GAIL SIMMONS: Once again,
it's almost happening.
SPEAKER: It is tiny bubbly.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm
going to slice this
into sort of like quarter
to half inch rings.
I don't want them too, too thin
because I want to keep them--
again, not to fall
through the crack.
And there's a little
bit of this tougher skin
here that I'm going to take off.
And then I'm going to
quarter my radicchio.
And I'm going to
grill that, too.
Radicchio is one of my
favorite lettuce to use.
It's sort of hearty and
beautiful and great this time
of year.
And it's great on the
grill, because it adds
a little bit of a smoky flavor.
And it's one of those
really simple things to do.
SPEAKER: I think people don't
think about that, necessarily,
grilling lettuces.
GAIL SIMMONS: Heartier lettuces
are really easy to grill.
I'm going to actually brush
these with a little oil,
too, just to make
sure that we don't
have any problems on the grill.
I love-- hearty
lettuces that are big,
that obviously
won't fall through,
are really great
for this purpose.
I love to grill romaine.
Delicious for a grilled Caesar.
SPEAKER: Grilled
Caesar is my favorite.
That was a surprise the
first time I had that one.
Why haven't I been doing
this my entire life?
GAIL SIMMONS: Right, well that's
how I feel about this radicchio
salad.
So perfect.
Little bit of salt, season
those up a little bit.
And then I'm going to put
them right on the grill
and do the same
with that radicchio.
I'm using kosher
salt, by the way.
I find that the
coarseness of the grain
is really easy to handle.
Fine, fine sea salt,
when you're cooking,
I like it for
finishing, perhaps,
and for other purposes.
But fine sea salt,
I find a little bit
difficult to measure
in your hand.
Because it's hard to tell
how much you're using.
So most cooks use kosher salt.
SPEAKER: We have arrived.
GAIL SIMMONS: All right!
SPEAKER: We are lentil ready.
GAIL SIMMONS: Awesome.
SPEAKER: Or salt, salt
ready prior to lentil.
GAIL SIMMONS: You want to throw
a generous pinch in there.
SPEAKER: Look at that!
GAIL SIMMONS: Keep going.
Keep going.
One more big one.
There you go.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Lentils, yeah, here?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, we'll trade.
When that boils again, which
will be in about 10 seconds,
you're going to dump
those lentils right in.
And then, would you set
your phone for 20 minutes?
SPEAKER: I appreciate
your use of resources.
GAIL SIMMONS: You know what?
It takes a village, people.
SPEAKER: What we need
is just an, OK Google.
Set a timer for 20 minutes.
GAIL SIMMONS: Hello, Google.
Isn't that what I'm
supposed to say?
SPEAKER: OK Google.
GAIL SIMMONS: OK Google, sorry.
I just got one, by the way.
Because listen to this, guys.
I have a friend who works
for Google in New York.
And she brought
me and my daughter
to the crazy donut
pop-up that we
did in Brooklyn last weekend.
And we went in
hoping to get donuts,
because my daughter
is three, and she
doesn't care about the devices.
And she would just
like to get a donut.
And so, you go and you
ask Google, OK Google,
answer the question.
And we got a-- we
got the whole thing!
A little donut!
And my daughter was
hugely disappointed.
[LAUGHTER]
Good thing they were
also handing out donuts.
And I was pretty
psyched about it.
Right, actual donuts.
SPEAKER: Now food,
there's always
food at Google everything.
It's an integral
part of our culture.
GAIL SIMMONS: Great
minds think alike.
Great minds think alike.
So I'm brushing a little bit
of oil onto the radicchio, too,
to make sure it
doesn't stick and burn.
And then I'm going to char it
up just a little bit as well.
SPEAKER: So romaine
and radicchio.
What are other
lettuces you think
hold up well on the grill?
GAIL SIMMONS: You
just want something
that has a bit more
of a heartiness to it.
So, you know, kale can work.
AUDIENCE: Cabbage?
GAIL SIMMONS: Well,
cabbage, sure.
Brussels sprouts in
the lettuce-y family.
So those are going
to go right on
and I probably have
to do both of these.
I see what's happening.
You can sort of hear
them starting to sizzle.
Tongs, yes, thank you.
OK, so my radicchio and
onions are grilling.
I'm cleaning my
station, also important.
Clean as you go.
And now I can add the oil
to this beautiful dressing.
I'm going to season it first
with some salt and pepper.
Looking good over there?
SPEAKER: Looking good.
GAIL SIMMONS: Great.
SPEAKER: It's getting
a little crazy.
Let's turn it down a little bit.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's OK.
OK, good.
No, that's good.
Moderate, thank you.
And then I'm just whisking in--
I could use a whisk, but there's
not that much liquid in here--
a few tablespoons of olive oil.
Keep whisking as
you move it around,
so that it incorporates.
But you don't have to worry
that much about emulsifying
a fancy dressing here.
Smoking, that's a good sign.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GAIL SIMMONS: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Is the shallot
going to emulsify?
GAIL SIMMONS: No, not really.
It's just the oil and the acid.
So it's really-- I mean, if
you want to get really crazy,
you can whisk it really,
really vigorously
and add the oil
really, really slowly.
And they'll ultimately
emulsify together.
SPEAKER: But not like
the required state
for this dressing?
GAIL SIMMONS: No, not at all.
I don't really believe--
when you're at
home and you just--
it's going to taste the same.
So my dressing's done.
SPEAKER: I think that
maybe did qualify
as the easiest dressing ever.
GAIL SIMMONS: Let's turn
this down just a little bit.
You can put a lid on that.
Do you think we
have a lid for that?
SPEAKER: I'm certain it exists
somewhere in this space.
Not certain exactly where.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
what we have Jared for.
SPEAKER: Jared is on it.
GAIL SIMMONS: He is all-knowing.
SPEAKER: He's the best.
GAIL SIMMONS: These are going
to fall through the grates
a little bit.
SPEAKER: And he legit found it.
Jared, you are a treasure.
Thank you so much.
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you, Jared.
SPEAKER: Works.
GAIL SIMMONS: Perfect!
SPEAKER: It's scrappy.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's sealing it.
All right.
SPEAKER: Love it.
Look at the grill marks going.
GAIL SIMMONS: I just want to
move these around a little bit,
make sure that all sides
get really lightly grilled.
You know, the radicchio
does change color a bit
from that really vibrant purple.
It'll get a little brown,
but it doesn't matter.
And then we're good.
Any questions so
far about anything?
Me, I'm an open
book, except if you
want to know the
winner of this season.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
one child, one daughter?
GAIL SIMMONS: I
have one daughter.
SPEAKER: She has one daughter.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes,
she's almost four.
She was a princess
kitty cat last night,
in case anyone was concerned.
SPEAKER: I think that was
a pretty popular costume,
in fact.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah,
it's a hybrid.
It's a mash-up.
SPEAKER: Princess kitty.
GAIL SIMMONS: Princess-- she
had her kitty [? parade ?]
doll with her.
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: And yeah,
she was rocking it.
Apparently, she got a good haul.
I was sadly not there.
SPEAKER: Yeah, well, I will
ask you a question selfishly.
What was your favorite
season of "Top Chef"?
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, my god.
I mean, it's hard to say.
Because we've been able to--
I mean, there's sort of like
two things about each season.
There's the talent and then
there's the city, you know?
And both are so
important to the season.
So I think of--
I think of those
as separate things.
SPEAKER: OK, so
separate things, then.
GAIL SIMMONS: I would say--
I would say season
six in Las Vegas
was my favorite season in
terms of the challenges
and the chef talent and sort
of the magic of that cast.
SPEAKER: And remind us
who was in that one.
GAIL SIMMONS: That was Michael
Voltaggio, Bryan Voltaggio.
SPEAKER: Oh, that's
my favorite season!
Jen and Kevin.
Yeah, that was the season.
GAIL SIMMONS: They
were feisty, man.
SPEAKER: They still are.
GAIL SIMMONS: They
certainly are.
They certainly are.
And they've all done
incredibly well.
SPEAKER: Yeah, they have.
GAIL SIMMONS: I was
at Vice the other day.
And they were talking about
how Kevin Gillespie had--
he's an Atlanta chef who has
done really, really well.
He's brilliant!
Really, really one of
the smartest guys I know.
SPEAKER: I thought he
was going to win, yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: You know, we all--
you know, it's anybody's game.
So they were talking
about how he was coming in
to do something the next day.
And they're like, do
you know that guy?
Do you know know who
Kevin Gillespie is?
Asking as if they were,
like, breaking news to me
about this rising star chef.
And I was like Kevin
Gillespie, yeah!
I fucking made that guy.
SPEAKER: Right?
You're, like, do I know him?
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm
totally joking.
I didn't swear, either.
And that can be bleeped
out in the stream.
SPEAKER: It's certainly
not going to be!
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, not that
I did, because it's all him.
I mean, he's amazing.
So that was an incredible cast.
SPEAKER: That
season was special,
I feel like, with the cast.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah,
it really was.
That was the season we won
our Emmy and for good reason.
Because there was
something about the casting
of that season that was
just amazing, the talent.
SPEAKER: I think that I always
felt that season had the most
chefs of the same caliber.
Usually there's-- usually
there's a couple who are
amazing.
That one was, like-- it really
could have been any of them.
GAIL SIMMONS: It
really could have been.
So that was incredible.
SPEAKER: Then city-wise?
GAIL SIMMONS: Favorite city?
Probably New Orleans, season 11.
We were there-- it was the
longest season we ever had.
It was an 18 or
19 episode season.
SPEAKER: An excuse to hang
out in NOLA a little longer.
GAIL SIMMONS: We were
like, no problem!
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: We were there
for like, I don't know,
eight or 10 weeks, and it was,
by the way, May through July.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
GAIL SIMMONS: So it was swampy.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: But
it was amazing.
I was pregnant, so I was
the only sober person
in the town of New Orleans--
SPEAKER: Oh no!
GAIL SIMMONS: --for 10 weeks.
Yeah.
And I had the best time ever.
I ate snowballs
every single day.
You guys know New
Orleans snowballs?
They're like shaved ice.
There's actually a recipe in my
book for a satsuma and ginger
granita that I discovered.
I use mandarins or
tangerines in the recipe,
because it's hard to get
satsumas in all of the country.
in the dessert section.
It's a ginger and mint
and tangerine granita
with condensed milk
drizzled on top.
SPEAKER: Sounds amazing.
GAIL SIMMONS: That was my
order every single day.
And you ask if my daughter
has a sweet tooth.
Like, literally, it's all
I ate for a long time.
SPEAKER: I mean, it
sounds fantastic.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
It was a special season.
I had spent time in New
Orleans before, but never
for that amount of time.
And the city is just an
incredible, generous,
fascinating place, and
I think so, so different
than the rest of the country.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's a
very unique, cultural--
SPEAKER: Very unique, yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: --place to live.
It's beautiful.
SPEAKER: So how's your salad?
GAIL SIMMONS: It's going great.
We're going to take
the beautiful radicchio
off the grill.
You can see it's nice
and charred on the edges,
but not too burned.
I think the onions can still
survive another moment or two.
I'm going to let them
soften a little bit.
Turn this side off,
and I'm just going
to chop these up very loosely.
I'm going to cut off the core,
because they're kind of hard.
And then I'm just going to
chop it roughly like that.
SPEAKER: Did you test these
recipes on your daughter?
GAIL SIMMONS: Many
of them, actually.
She is a very particular critic.
SPEAKER: Is that all kids?
Because mine sure are.
GAIL SIMMONS: As three
year olds are, yeah.
If anyone has
toddlers, they know
exactly what I'm talking about.
She was great with a lot
of the recipes, actually.
There's a few recipes
that were inspired
by things we cooked together.
Pancakes that are
in there, certainly
a couple of the egg dishes.
She totally got into the
desserts-- go figure.
SPEAKER: It's a terrible thing.
GAIL SIMMONS: But
even the things I
didn't think she would love.
There's a spaghetti
pie recipe in there
that sort of this amazing,
monstrous, delicious,
serves 25--
SPEAKER: Sold.
GAIL SIMMONS:
--weighs 40 pounds.
SPEAKER: Sold.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's
[INAUDIBLE] of course.
I mean, there was no
surprise that she was really
into the spaghetti pie.
But she also loved the banana
cardamom cake, which I thought
would be a little
bit spiced for her.
And she totally loved
it and ate it up.
And she's a pretty
good eater, overall.
She's a toddler, so every day
is a little bit different.
What she liked yesterday, she
will bluntly refuse today.
SPEAKER: How dare you
insult her by thinking--
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes.
SPEAKER: --that she
was going eat it again.
GAIL SIMMONS: Throw
it across the room.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah, been there.
GAIL SIMMONS: But mostly
she's a great eater,
and I feel lucky about that.
So we cook together
a lot and she
loves to get in the kitchen,
and I think that helps.
SPEAKER: Oh, for sure.
I mean, I have a
daughter who's 12,
and she just started cooking
dinner for us once a week,
which is the best
thing ever, by the way.
GAIL SIMMONS: I would
pay big bucks for that.
If she's looking
for more clients.
SPEAKER: I know.
Well, we started doing
the meal delivery thing
and trying it out.
And then that demystified
it enough for her
that she was like,
I want to try this.
GAIL SIMMONS: I can do this.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's amazing.
I mean, that's cool.
SPEAKER: But talk
about game changer.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: But yeah, having her
just comfortable in the kitchen
now, it's really resulting
in benefit to my busy life.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
the end result.
SPEAKER: And ultimately--
GAIL SIMMONS: How
does this benefit me?
SPEAKER: Well, and
I also told her,
think about the life skills.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, 100%.
SPEAKER: I didn't start
cooking like that.
GAIL SIMMONS: And the
math and the science.
SPEAKER: Right?
All of it.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's
useful, but I also
think ownership allows
them to have confidence.
I mean, my child at
three is much more
likely to eat her dinner
if she played a hand in it.
SPEAKER: 100% agree.
The things that
she will try now,
or that she'll
fully eat and enjoy
because she made it
herself is really powerful.
And I just taught
my son this weekend
how to make chocolate
chip cookies,
so we're going to set
the stage correctly.
GAIL SIMMONS: So she's got
dinner and he's got dessert
and you're sold.
SPEAKER: And I get to sit down--
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, wow.
SPEAKER: --which doesn't
happen very often.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, exactly.
Can you get your partner
or spouse to do the dishes?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
what you need to do.
SPEAKER: I think that's one
of those things where it's not
as intimidating to,
yeah, let's clean up,
if I didn't have to
do all the things that
come before that, right?
GAIL SIMMONS: You're
totally right.
My husband is not a cook, but
he is an excellent dish washer.
SPEAKER: Hey, it
takes all kinds.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah,
he's a little bit OCD.
Like, he really is very
particular about cleanliness.
SPEAKER: So I would
pay big bucks for that.
So we should work out a trade.
GAIL SIMMONS: He's
available for hire.
SPEAKER: Yes!
We will work out a trade.
My daughter will make dinner
and your husband can clean up.
GAIL SIMMONS: Done.
So I have my grilled onions.
SPEAKER: They smell amazing.
GAIL SIMMONS: They're going in.
SPEAKER: Sorry,
livestream friends.
They smell amazing.
GAIL SIMMONS: They do.
The thing about onions is that
they're full of sugar, right?
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
so that's when you
say "caramelizing" onions
is really cooking them
so that the natural
sugars come out.
The char is from
the sugar content.
And so that's what
you want-- sweetness.
They really add a
lot of sweetness.
How much time do we
have on the lentils
SPEAKER: Yeah, I was just going
to say, Laura, how we doing?
GAIL SIMMONS: We're
going to fake it anyway.
AUDIENCE: Eight minutes.
GAIL SIMMONS: OK, great.
SPEAKER: Eight
minutes on our timer.
We got 30 minutes
left on our cook.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'll
show you what to do,
but I'm still going to just
put together the salad.
Because I happen to
have, through the magic
of television, some
cooked lentils.
So basically all you do
when the lentils are cooked
is you strain them out,
pull out the bay leaf,
pull out the garlic, and then
lie them out on a sheet tray
to cool.
And you want them
to cool completely,
because they'll continue
to cook if you keep them
in pot or in a bowl together
because of the heat being
retained.
So if you spread them out,
they'll cool much faster
and that will stop the cooking.
SPEAKER: That's a good tip.
GAIL SIMMONS: And then you
just add them right in.
I'm also going to add
some sliced fennel.
SPEAKER: Mm.
GAIL SIMMONS: Which I love.
I think fennel is an underrated
and delicious vegetable that I
put in a lot of my salads.
SPEAKER: Totally agree.
And we just had some on
the breakfast line at MP1
this morning if were over there.
GAIL SIMMONS: Delicious.
Oh, fennel fronds.
Do you guys have
a little of them?
SPEAKER: Yep, right there.
We gotcha.
GAIL SIMMONS: Just a tiny bit.
So I'm going to dress--
thank you so much, Jared--
I'm going to dress this
salad at this point
before I put in the arugula,
because I want all of this
to absorb the dressing.
If I put the arugula in too
it will wilt really quickly.
And this way it will be better--
like, if you're making a
dinner party or something
and you want to dress it to
let all the dressing absorb
but you don't want to wilt the
lettuce too far in advance.
So I'm just going to pour
that dressing right over top,
and I'm going to give
that a little spin.
Another good tip
about making salads
that people don't think about so
much is use a really big bowl.
SPEAKER: So you can toss it well
and really get it all in there.
GAIL SIMMONS: So you can
toss it really easily.
Because so many times
you put your salad
in this tiny salad
bowl, and then it's
so difficult to sauce.
You know exactly what
I'm talking about, right?
Right.
Then I'm just going to add in--
and there's enough dressing
that it'll coat the
arugula, so you really
don't need to worry about that.
SPEAKER: A little
bit of fennel frond.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
some fresh basil.
And then the fronds
from the fennel
that you sliced earlier,
save those fronds,
they are so full of flavor, and
just add a little bit there.
Thank you, chef.
And then you give it
all a toss together.
And you can do this
stage a little bit later.
If you're having a dinner
party or something,
you can make the
salad up to the point
where you've dressed the
lentils and the onions
and the radicchio together and
let them sit for a little bit.
And then add the arugula
at the really last minute.
SPEAKER: It looks
beautiful, too.
The color's great,
super vibrant.
GAIL SIMMONS: Totally.
SPEAKER: Dressing
smells amazing.
AUDIENCE: What's your
favorite dish from the book?
SPEAKER: What's your
GAIL SIMMONS: God, it's so hard.
SPEAKER: See, with
one kid you don't have
to be asked your favorite kid.
GAIL SIMMONS: I never have
to answer that question.
SPEAKER: This is like a
derivative of that question.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's true.
They're my babies.
I would say there's so
many, because they're all
so different and the
recipes-- as I said,
I'm just putting a little bit
of fresh herbs right on top
like that.
AUDIENCE: Or, what would
you eat most often?
SPEAKER: Yeah, what would
you eat again and again
and again and again?
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going
to give that to you,
and we have some extra
salad here if you want it.
What can I eat most often?
I mean, I could eat that
spaghetti pie all day.
It makes the best
leftovers of all time.
I mean, it can sit in
your fridge for a week.
So don't be shy to make it.
If you think you can't--
SPEAKER: Maybe you don't have
25 people too feed it to,
still make it.
GAIL SIMMONS: Exactly.
Still make it.
It's like cold pizza.
It's the best thing ever.
I'm also just going
to give these to you,
Jared, if you don't mind.
Thank you so much.
I love that.
I love the banana
cardamom upside-down cake.
I love the black
licorice chocolate cake.
SPEAKER: We got you.
GAIL SIMMONS: I mean, we're
good with the lentils,
but I do want to finish
them and show you guys just
for the sake of showing you.
I love-- I don't know.
There's so many things
that I love in the book.
I love the lamb chops
a la [? friettes. ?]
Sort of a Spanish inspired dish.
Lamb chops grilled with
roasted grapes and sweet onions
and lemon, and I drizzle smoked
paprika honey all over it.
SPEAKER: Yum.
GAIL SIMMONS: Easiest, great
entertaining main course.
SPEAKER: Smoked paprika honey
is now burned into my brain.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: I will not be able
to stop thinking about that.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's so easy.
SPEAKER: --until
I read the book.
GAIL SIMMONS: I mean,
literally, I just take honey,
put a little bit of paprika
in, stir it up, put it
in the microwave for five
seconds so it's a little warm
and it thins out,
and you drizzle it
on top of the lamb chops.
SPEAKER: What is this, Gail?
You are blowing
my mind right now.
GAIL SIMMONS: It's so good.
All right, fish soup--
everybody ready?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: This is a
really simple fish soup
that is also really
great for a dinner party,
because it can be made almost
completely ahead of time.
And then the fish itself you
put in at the last minute,
and it takes two
minutes to cook.
SPEAKER: Oh, perfect.
GAIL SIMMONS: If you
are having people over
and you make the
dish in advance,
literally the whole thing
takes a half an hour
to make in advance.
Put it on the side of the
stove, don't think about it.
And then people come
over or dinner is ready
and you put the fish
in for two minutes.
You bring it up to
temperature, put the fish
in for two minutes, and you have
the most beautiful, elegant,
really impressive dish.
And it's hardy, and it's
tasty, and it's really yummy.
SPEAKER: So what do we do?
GAIL SIMMONS: So, I'm going to
start with onions, some garlic,
some celery, and more fennel.
SPEAKER: All good things
start with onions and garlic.
I feel like that's
just rules of life.
GAIL SIMMONS: I
totally agree with you.
Making soup is something
I'm sort of geeky
and passionate about.
There's a lot of
soup in the book.
There's a whole chapter
of soups and stews,
because I spend a lot of
time making soups and stews.
SPEAKER: Well, it's about
to be soup and stew weather.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
SPEAKER" Although maybe
in New York it already is.
GAIL SIMMONS: I don't believe
that that happens here,
but whatever you say.
SPEAKER: She's from Canada
where it gets really cold.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Right?
We adhere very strongly to
the 50 to 80 is really--
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, I know.
I feel real bad
for you about that.
SPEAKER: I do like coats though.
I don't get a chance
wear them very much.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, I know.
Well, come visit.
I'll give you an
excuse to wear them.
SPEAKER: Sold.
GAIL SIMMONS: Actually there's
a couple of chilled soups
also in the book, which I
love and make all year round.
There's a Romesco
style gazpacho,
which is a Spanish gazpacho
but with walnuts and roasted
peppers.
But it's very quick.
SPEAKER: Super fast [INAUDIBLE].
GAIL SIMMONS: I make a chilled
corn soup, which is also
really beautiful for summer.
But I do a lot of
soups and stews
from a riff on my
mom's matzo ball soup
and my grandmother
matzo ball soup to I
do a big pork and bean soup
with maple cream from Quebec
because I lived in
Montreal for a long time.
And then I have this rustic fish
soup which is sort of Italian
inspired-- it's a hot pan--
and really simple and flavorful.
I'm starting with some
fennel and onions.
I'm going to grab
a wooden spoon.
SPEAKER: Ya ta ta, Jared!
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you so much.
Magic.
SPEAKER: Magic of Jared.
GAIL SIMMONS: So I put a little
oil in the bottom of the pan,
let it heat up for a minute.
And then I added the
onions and fennel,
and I'm going to
let them cook down.
You want to hear that sizzle.
That's a good thing.
People always ask about how
you know when pans are hot,
and people worry about burning.
But the most important
thing I think about cooking
is that it really uses
all five of your senses.
It's the only art that I
can think of that does that.
You need to hear that sizzle
to know your pan is hot.
And you also can tell
if it's too high pitched
that it might be too hot.
If you're not hearing that when
you put something on a grill,
or when you put something
into fat in a pan or a pot,
then it's not ready.
And you want the integrity
of it hitting the pan
and caramelizing, or
getting color and being hot.
So I'm going to put that in.
And you can't
really see into it,
but you'll start
smelling it soon--
unless you're
watching this online.
SPEAKER: Smells
amazing, online friends.
Thanks for watching
the livestream.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
then I'm going to add
some celery, chopped celery,
and then a little bit of garlic.
You know, maybe a
little more garlic.
SPEAKER: I was going to say.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going to let
that cook for a few minutes.
I don't want it to get too brown
and take on too much color.
Because the downside
of caramelizing
anything is that there's
a moment where it then
gets bitter.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: It goes from
sweetness and lovely smokiness
to bitterness, and I don't
want any of that in my soup,
of course.
So I'm going to let that
cook for just a sec.
Is the time up on the lentils?
SPEAKER: Yes, it is.
GAIL SIMMONS: Cool.
Let's just show you how that's
done, in case you're wondering.
I'm just going to--
ooh.
All good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's the life of a chef.
AUDIENCE: Who's your
favorite guest [? judge? ?]
SPEAKER: Oh, who's
your favorite guest
judge who works at [INAUDIBLE]?
GAIL SIMMONS: That's
a good question.
SPEAKER: Let's post this online
after you answer this question.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's a
hard question, actually.
I'm trying to think.
SPEAKER 1: Do you
need some hands?
GAIL SIMMONS: We've worked
with so many amazing people
over the years.
No, I'm good.
I'm just going to--
SPEAKER: Oh, right
on your sheet pan.
GAIL SIMMONS: --shake it out and
put it right on the sheet pan,
and that way that will
cool off really quickly.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
GAIL SIMMONS: Let
me think for a sec.
There The Foo Fighters--
they were kind of amazing.
AUDIENCE: The Food Fighters.
GAIL SIMMONS: The
Food Fighters--
who, by the way, are great
cooks and super exciting.
And they were awesome about
being on the show with us.
We did a challenge where we
made our chefs cook for them
backstage right before
a concert and then
we all went to the concert.
That was awesome.
SPEAKER: It's a good excuse
to go to the concert.
GAIL SIMMONS: I remember
I'm standing backstage
and we're about to go on, and
the lead singer of the Foo
Fighters, like Dave--
I'm just going to call him
Dave, because he's my buddy now.
SPEAKER: Because you're
buddies and you should.
GAIL SIMMONS: Turns
to me and he's
like, I can't believe
I'm on "Top Chef."
And I'm like, I can't believe
you're the Foo Fighters.
SPEAKER: Win-win!
High five!
GAIL SIMMONS: That
was kind of exciting.
SPEAKER: That is fun.
GAIL SIMMONS: Joel
Robuchon came on the show.
SPEAKER: Sure.
That was pretty exciting.
GAIL SIMMONS: That was
really amazing for us
in our Vegas season.
Because as much as we've had
the best chefs in this country,
it was rare to get one of
the real old school, French--
SPEAKER: Real,
real, upper-echelon.
GAIL SIMMONS:
--upper-echelon chefs.
That was a real
highlight for all of us.
Even Tom was
intimidated that day.
Natalie Portman was a
really fun challenge.
That was a vegan challenge.
SPEAKER: Yeah,
because she's vegan.
GAIL SIMMONS: And that
was sort of exciting,
because it was not only her and
she was obviously a delight,
but that was really
when we could
do a vegan challenge
which people have been
asking us to do for a while.
And this was, again, five
or six years ago when
the chef world was like, vegan
challenge, that's ridiculous.
But it was a true challenge,
and we made beautiful food.
They made beautiful
food that day.
SPEAKER: We talk
about the complexity
of cooking really delicious
vegan food here quite a bit.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, I bet.
SPEAKER: Our chef community
feels pretty strongly.
It's actually more difficult
to cook vegetables perfectly,
right?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes.
SPEAKER: And then to create
a really robust vegan
meal that feels like a meal--
GAIL SIMMONS: Right.
And satisfying.
SPEAKER: Right, exactly.
GAIL SIMMONS: And balanced,
and all those things.
My father at the age
of 75 became a vegan
a couple of years ago.
SPEAKER: Really?
GAIL SIMMONS: Damn him.
It drives my mother and I crazy,
but I'm really proud of him
about it.
I mean, I really admire
him for doing it.
And it has challenged me
a lot when he comes over
and when I cook for him.
And also, taking
him out for dinner,
which is a little bit more
difficult than it used to be,
but that's OK.
So there's actually a couple
of vegan recipes in the book,
specifically made for my dad.
SPEAKER: Oh, that's awesome.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
Wine.
Oh, actually I'm
going to use this one.
Half a cup of white wine.
If you have pernod
around, pernod
is also great to
use in this dish
because it has a little
bit of an anise note to it.
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going to
add about a half a cup of wine
in there.
And I'm going to let that
reduce out a little bit
until it's almost
completely gone.
So I've taken all the alcohol
away and all that's left
is the flavor of that wine.
AUDIENCE: What are three
favorite or must-go-to
restaurants in New York?
SPEAKER: Oh, three favorite
restaurants in New York.
GAIL SIMMONS: You guys are
really hard balling it today.
SPEAKER: People have been
thinking about these questions.
Usually they're a lot
more like a riff off.
These are good,
calculating questions.
I appreciate that.
GAIL SIMMONS: But no, I do, too.
So here's my rule about giving
restaurant recommendations
in New York.
You need to give me
either a cuisine or--
SPEAKER: Narrow
the playing field?
GAIL SIMMONS: --a neighborhood.
SPEAKER: Yeah, you got to narrow
the playing field a little bit.
GAIL SIMMONS: Because
it's overwhelming,
as it is in San Francisco.
And also, I can't even keep up
anymore, there's just so many.
SPEAKER: So many all the time.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
there's so many I love.
And I rarely get to
go to a restaurant
more than once or twice.
So--
AUDIENCE: West Village?
GAIL SIMMONS: West Village.
SPEAKER: West Village.
GAIL SIMMONS: OK,
I can do that one.
No, I'm pretty good
at doing them all.
I would say in the West
Village I am in love
with Buvette, which is a
beautiful little French cafe
with amazing small plates, great
breakfast, beautiful coffee.
And it just has that
way of transporting you.
Right across the street, the
same owner and her partner
have an Italian restaurant
called Via Carota,
and it's also really delicious.
I'm an old school fan of
Mary's Fish Camp, which
is like a classic lobster roll
place in New York which still
has lineups out the
door for two hours,
even though it's been
open for 15 years.
SPEAKER: Wow.
That's testament in itself.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, it is.
I mean, it's tiny.
The West Village
is known for having
a lot of tiny great spots.
AUDIENCE: Favorite in Chelsea?
SPEAKER: Oh,
favorite in Chelsea,
which is where our new
Google office is going.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah,
I have been there.
I lived on 16th Street for
10 years, 16th and 7th,
and Google's at 16th
between 8th and 9th, right?
SPEAKER: And we're building out
a whole new thing in Chelsea.
GAIL SIMMONS: Well, there
you go, I'll go check it out.
SPEAKER: The pier.
We're taking that whole thing.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, right,
you're taking that pier.
So that's intimidating.
That part of the city did not
have a great day yesterday.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: But we will rise.
SPEAKER: Always.
GAIL SIMMONS: Again.
So Chelsea, that was my
hood for a really long time.
I love a lot of
restaurants in Chelsea.
Chelsea's a funny neighborhood.
The food has changed a lot
in a very short time there.
There's a really amazing
spot called Haven's Kitchen
on 17th Street.
It's a coffee shop and
little cafe by day,
and their food is really great.
And then they have a
cooking and teaching
space and a catering company,
and they do cooking classes,
and they have a beautiful
private event space.
I am adding some
fish stock to this.
If you don't have fish stock
or not up to making fish stock,
which you don't have to do,
you can use some clam juice.
Just a bottle of clam
juice, like eight ounces
of clam juice, and that's going
to be the basis of this soup.
SPEAKER: Our beautiful leader's
telling us we have 10 minutes.
SPEAKER: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: OK, so what
about your favorite vegan
restaurant [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: Oh, your
favorite vegan restaurant.
GAIL SIMMONS: Sure.
Superiority Burger
is sort of amazing.
SPEAKER: Superiority Burger?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
It's not [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: That is the most
vegan thing I've ever heard.
GAIL SIMMONS: They are
the most amazing burgers.
AUDIENCE: They are.
GAIL SIMMONS: They're awesome.
In with the stock.
SPEAKER: That's the best
name for a vegan restaurant.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
In with the stock is
a can of tomatoes.
You can get whole and
just mash them up,
or buy crushed
tomatoes if you want.
And then I'm going to
add some chili pepper,
some grated orange zest.
I put citrus zest in general
in almost all of my food,
because I find it so delicious.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
GAIL SIMMONS: And it
brings so much to it.
SPEAKER: Greatness.
Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
then some fresh thyme.
You can just add the
whole stem if you want to.
SPEAKER: Because
picking thyme leaves
is the most annoying
kitchen task.
GAIL SIMMONS: Well,
except I'm going
to show you a little tip
about the thyme leaves.
SPEAKER: Please make
it a easier for me.
GAIL SIMMONS: The fastest
way to pick a thyme leaf is
to turn it down like this.
So, the leaves
are all facing up.
If you put your hand at the
top and then just go down,
all of them are off and then
you don't have to worry about--
SPEAKER: With the
strong stems, yes.
And when the stems are
weak they break on you
and it's the most
annoying thing.
GAIL SIMMONS: That's true.
It is annoying.
That's why I say,
if you're going
to put the whole thing in,
remember to take it out
because it's not
so nice otherwise.
SPEAKER: Spoon that
right into your mouth.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going
to season this up just
a little bit with some
salt. And then I'm
going to bring this
to a boil, and I'm
going to let it simmer
for about 25 minutes.
And then that'll be
the base for your soup.
And if you want to
turn it off right there
and put it inside of your stove
until you're ready to cook
the fish, that's done.
And then you're going
to cook the fish in it.
And I, through the
magic of television,
have some done right here.
SPEAKER: Ta-da!
AUDIENCE: Will we see
a successful risotto
on this season?
SPEAKER: Do they make a
successful [INAUDIBLE]??
It's only happened one time.
GAIL SIMMONS: It has happened,
and it is a hard thing to do.
It's like, they can't
help themselves.
SPEAKER: That's my thing--
they keep doing it.
They just keep going back to it.
GAIL SIMMONS: It is a
very competitive field,
and they all think they're
going to take it down,
like they are going to conquer.
SPEAKER: Well, someone
I feel like did one
in one of the later--
towards the end--
and Tom actually--
GAIL SIMMONS:
Right, that's true.
Because when you only
have to cook for a smaller
amount of people and you're
not one of 15 cooking,
you're more likely.
SPEAKER: But I feel like it
was even maybe the finale
or right before.
GAIL SIMMONS: I think
it was right before.
SPEAKER: Right before, yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: I kept
forgetting, because truthfully--
SPEAKER: It was just
a small dinner party.
GAIL SIMMONS: I have no memory
of eating [INAUDIBLE] dishes.
SPEAKER: Well, you've
done 15 seasons?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
And five spin-offs.
I mean, there's just no
way to remember it all.
SPEAKER: Right, so
what kind of fish?
GAIL SIMMONS: So
this is sea bass,
but you can really use any
firm, white fish that you want.
If you see halibut or tilapia--
cod would be great.
It all cooks really quickly,
and it's all really good for you
and delicious.
I'm just going to
slice it up very gently
and cube it into
one-inch pieces.
And then I'm putting it
right into the pot that
should be lightly simmering.
And it'll cook in
about two minutes,
and then you're
literally done and you
can serve the whole
thing, which I will do.
[? Skip-- ?] oh,
that's hot already.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a genre of food
that you prefer not to cook or
find particularly challenging?
SPEAKER: What type of
genre food to not cook?
GAIL SIMMONS: You know, that's
an interesting question.
That's a question I've
have never had before,
because everyone ask me
what's your favorite cuisine
or genre to cook in or eat.
And my answer is
always that, because we
live in the amazing
places we live,
I can eat and cook a different
cuisine every single day.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: I could
eat Mexican for breakfast
and Filipino for lunch
and Vietnamese for dinner,
and then go out for incredible
sushi as a midnight snack,
or whatever I want.
For cooking purposes,
I would say Japanese
beyond making simple
ramen or udon,
because it's hard to get
the quality of ingredients--
like, if I want to do really
elaborate Japanese food.
And it's also the training,
which is at a different level.
I don't cook it at
home, but that's not
to say I don't use the
flavors that I love
from Japanese food-- really good
soy, and yuzu, and togarashi,
and that kind of thing that
I love to put into my food.
I love cooking other food
that uses similar flavors.
I love Indonesian food, and
Vietnamese food-- both of which
there's a lot of in the book, a
couple of dishes from Singapore
from our time spent
there when we shot
the seventh season of the show.
But I don't cook classic,
really elaborate Japanese food
at home that much.
Oh, we got a rapid boil.
I love this kitchen.
SPEAKER: It's an
induction, I tell you.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GAIL SIMMONS: Never.
I cannot speak for
other food shows,
but on our show we realized
very quickly that obviously it
affects the quality of the
food and how we judge it,
and we never wait for food.
So it doesn't matter--
I'm trying to wash
my hands quickly.
It doesn't matter if
my dress isn't done up
or my makeup's not on or my
mic is improperly positioned
or anyone's running late.
When the food is hot, we eat it.
SPEAKER: Good.
GAIL SIMMONS: And our
associate director--
SPEAKER: That's good to hear.
GAIL SIMMONS: --who runs
the stage is very adamant
about that, and rightly so.
Because that's
the nature of what
we do, and we want
to give these chefs
the respect that they deserve.
SPEAKER: And if it's going to
be a real cooking show, right?
GAIL SIMMONS: That's right.
They're professional chefs.
These are not amateurs who think
it would be cool to be a chef.
These are all guys and
girls who have been cooking
for 10-plus years at
the highest level,
and so we really want to respect
the food that they're cooking
and eat it as hot as we can.
What you don't see on the show
which makes that a lot easier,
is that the chefs
cook in a stagger.
SPEAKER: Ah.
GAIL SIMMONS: So everyone
often thinks that they're all
cooking at the same time.
So the last person
cooking, of course
their food's going to be
cold by the time it gets--
or the last person whose
food is presented for eating.
But actually they cook in
staggers usually of three.
So let's say it's
a two-hour cook.
The first three will go, and
they'll cook for 20 minutes,
and then the next
three will start.
So there's a 20-minute
gap between them.
So that when we're
eating, we eat the first
and we have 20 minutes to
eat it and talk about it
before the next comes out.
SPEAKER: Editing, right?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: It's all
in the editing.
GAIL SIMMONS:
Well, and that also
allows us to eat, have a
discussion about it, clear.
Sometimes it's been a
half an hour, 20 minutes
to half an hour, but
it also makes sure
that we're getting their
food as soon as it comes off
the [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: That makes
a ton of sense.
Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, exactly.
Pardon?
SPEAKER: Even the quickfire?
GAIL SIMMONS: Quickfire's
a little different.
So quickfire, they all have
to be done at the same time,
but they go through
them really quickly.
Padma speaks to them with the
guest chef for three minutes
each, and they move on.
So they go really quickly
around that kitchen.
SPEAKER: Other questions
while she's plating
this amazing smelling soup?
AUDIENCE: So the
holidays are coming up.
SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you recommend
certain things [INAUDIBLE]??
SPEAKER: Ooh, what shall we
make this holiday season?
GAIL SIMMONS: Absolutely.
I sort of regret that there's
not a traditional turkey
in my book.
There is a turkey.
It's a pastrami turkey.
So I've roasted the turkey
with the flavors of pastrami,
and it's really delicious, and
it's sort of rolled and sliced,
boned out.
So it's an untraditional turkey,
and if you want to make it,
I guarantee you'll
be happy about it.
And the flavor is awesome
because sometimes turkey flavor
is pretty bland.
But there's lots
of other things.
So for Thanksgiving there is
an amazing salt and vinegar
smashed potatoes, which is
actually in "People" magazine--
I just saw it today, so I guess
it's in this week's issue--
that I did in the book.
There's a lot of holiday
baking, you said.
So the black licorice chocolate
cake I mentioned before I think
is amazing.
There's two tarts in the book--
one is a very traditional
Canadian tart called
a [? tarto ?] [? sook, ?] and it
is a maple sugar tart which is
a very traditional dish that
you eat at sugar shacks all over
Quebec when sugaring
season happens,
which sort of starts now
and goes through March.
And it has a hazelnut
crust, and it's insanely
delicious and addictive.
The first time I ever made
the soup in the States,
I made it for Marcus
Samuelsson, who's
a chef in New York who
is a good friend of mine.
And we had a show together
for a brief time on a network
called FYI.
And I made it for him on
the show, and he sat--
I mean, he's a little man--
and he ate an entire
half of a pie.
SPEAKER: And then you
bounced around the room
on a sugar high?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, exactly.
Delicious.
And then there's a banoffee
pie, which if you're not a baker
I highly recommend, because--
do you have any more
of those fronds?
Thank you.
Because it requires
no actual baking.
SPEAKER: It's an
assembly of ingredients?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes.
The only thing you have
to do is make or buy--
but I do teach you how to make--
dulce de leche out of a
can of condensed milk.
SPEAKER: Oh.
GAIL SIMMONS: And the
dulce de leche then
gets spread on the bottom of
a chocolate wafer crust, which
is just really chocolate wafers
that you buy in the grocery
store mixed with butter and
pressed into a pie plate.
And then layers
of sliced banana,
lots of whipped cream, chocolate
shavings and roasted peanuts.
SPEAKER: It sounds gross.
GAIL SIMMONS: And it is like
the most killer dessert.
SPEAKER: It doesn't
sound good at all.
GAIL SIMMONS: There's a
couple of good cookies, too.
There's a cookie in there
that is a vanilla cookie,
but it's a sandwich cookie with
dulce de leche in the middle
and dipped in chocolate
with a little sea salt,
and those are really
good holiday cookies.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yes, Gail.
So there you are.
GAIL SIMMONS: There you are.
So that's my fish stew.
It came together in moments.
SPEAKER: Really fast, yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, and my
grilled radicchio salad.
Thank you guys so much
for cooking with me.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
And because we're so spoiled and
Googlers eat all of the things,
everybody gets to taste
these delicious dishes.
And do you want to
do a little Q&A?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
If you guys have questions,
keep them coming.
I'm happy to answer.
I have a question for you guys.
Where should I eat
breakfast tomorrow morning
in San Francisco?
AUDIENCE: Our office?
GAIL SIMMONS: Right.
Could do that.
Any other favorites--
breakfast, brunch?
AUDIENCE: Tartine Manufactory.
GAIL SIMMONS:
Tartine Manufactory.
SPEAKER: Yeah,
GAIL SIMMONS: Where is Elise?
Noted, we're going to
Tartine Manufactory.
I forgot about it.
Of course.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Porcini
breakfast sandwich.
GAIL SIMMONS: Did you say
porcini breakfast sandwich?
Done.
Check and check.
SPEAKER: That place
is super delicious.
GAIL SIMMONS: Great.
Great.
AUDIENCE: Bread bowl?
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh,
yeah, that's a given.
SPEAKER: She ate at
[? Lavonne ?] earlier.
GAIL SIMMONS: I did,
I had my breakfast.
We got here really
early, and I had
breakfast at [? Lavonne ?]
which is delicious.
I had a trumpet mushroom strata.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Holmes Bakehouse.
SPEAKER: Oh yeah,
Mr. Holmes Bakehouse.
GAIL SIMMONS: I love--
I mean, that place is bananas.
So cool.
That will probably be like
a mid-afternoon snack.
SPEAKER: There you go.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going to
try to start with something
with some nutritional value.
SPEAKER: Yeah, put
a little base down.
GAIL SIMMONS: And then
I'll go to Mr. Holmes.
SPEAKER: I love it.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
be in Queens next week.
Any recommendations?
GAIL SIMMONS: In Queens?
SPEAKER: Queens recommendations?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, absolutely.
I mean, you should go to
PS1 to M. Wells, if you can.
A guy from Quebec actually who
cooks at the museum, the Modern
Art Museum at PS1
and gallery, and he
has an awesome restaurant.
It's in Long Island City.
Are you willing to
come to Brooklyn?
It's not far.
There's not even a real border.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, I mean,
come to Brooklyn, I say.
Let's see, if you're going
to drive a little bit,
you don't even need to go
into Manhattan these days.
I say go to Larina,
L-A-R-I-N-A, in Fort Greene.
If you guys watched our
last season of "Top Chef,"
there was an Italian chef named
Silvia Barban on the show.
She's so lovely, and she opened
this restaurant a year ago.
My mother-in-law went
last night actually
and said it was amazing.
But I went over the summer
and just blown away.
It's simple, beautiful,
Italian food.
SPEAKER: She was so sweet.
GAIL SIMMONS: She
was very sweet.
SPEAKER: Edited to seem sweet.
GAIL SIMMONS: No, no.
SPEAKER: Now I'm suspicious.
GAIL SIMMONS: That is their true
selves, just like it's also me.
It's just a bit of
a curated version.
I wear more cocktail dresses
in my "Top Chef" life.
SPEAKER: You have the best
cocktail dresses on that show.
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you.
I will tell the woman who's
in charge of that job,
because it's not me.
SPEAKER: Please do.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes, I
would fail miserably
if I had to do that job myself.
SPEAKER: You guys
like the salad?
EVERYONE: Yeah.
GAIL SIMMONS: So is
everything, yeah, good?
Thank you, Chef
[? Didi, ?] by the way,
and both Alma and Jared, they
did such an amazing job today.
SPEAKER: Thank you guys so much.
Usually what happens is
we're talking and talking,
and then everybody
gets real quiet.
And that's how we know
everything is super delicious.
AUDIENCE: The grilled
radicchio [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: Grilled
radicchio, next level?
AUDIENCE: I'm obsessed now.
GAIL SIMMONS: I agree.
SPEAKER: So [? Didi, ?] we need
to do a grilled salads class.
GAIL SIMMONS:
Grilled salads class.
Oh!
I'd come, totally.
SPEAKER: So we were
speaking earlier about--
GAIL SIMMONS: I was
think I'm moving in.
SPEAKER: --the classes
that we have here,
and she wants to come and
do a series of classes.
And I think we would all
support that whenever she could
make time in her busy schedule.
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm going to
be like artist-in-residence,
just right in this kitchen.
I'm going to sleep under the--
SPEAKER: You can be a member
of the Google Food Team.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: We'll make
you an honorary member.
GAIL SIMMONS: The
thing about the book
that I really tried to
do with every recipe is
make it super simple.
Ultimately it's a lentil
and lettuce salad, right?
SPEAKER: Sure.
GAIL SIMMONS: And
if you take out
the grilling of
the radicchio, it's
a salad that you can
probably get anywhere.
But that one extra step of
grilling the radicchio I think
really changes the
salad, makes you
think a little more about
cooking and pumping up
the flavor in your dish,
and using maybe a technique
that you wouldn't use.
So all the recipes in the
book I think have that.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
That's that special thing
that makes it really
value add, like learn
something besides just
getting inspiration,
which is always good.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, exactly.
I want people to not just follow
a recipe verbatim, but actually
start to understand the reasons
that a recipe are written
the way that they're
written, and feel confident
following the recipe so much
so that then they can move away
from the recipe and start
really cooking spontaneously,
but based in the
proper technique.
AUDIENCE: If you weren't
a cook-- a chef--
or in the food industry--
GAIL SIMMONS: I'm not a chef.
She's a chef.
AUDIENCE: --what
would you want to be?
What would you do?
SPEAKER: What's your dream job?
GAIL SIMMONS: You
know, I love my job.
SPEAKER: It's a pretty good one.
GAIL SIMMONS: But
my answer is always
that I would want to be a
primatologist, a zoologist.
SPEAKER: Really?
GAIL SIMMONS: Yeah, I
really love monkeys.
I studied anthropology--
physical and cultural
anthropology-- in
college, because my way in
was I really love monkeys.
Like, I'm fascinated by
primates, which we all are,
technically.
Yeah, I think I would be
a zoologist, if I could.
SPEAKER: That's fascinating.
GAIL SIMMONS: Probably an
assistant to a zoologist
because no one
would really trust
me to be the head zoologist.
SPEAKER: I mean, you never know.
GAIL SIMMONS: Yes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Oh, what spices
are low key overlooked?
GAIL SIMMONS: Definitely.
A lot.
And I use a lot of spices in
this book in very subtle ways.
Ground ginger, ground
cardamom, certainly,
paprika, I use a lot of smoked
paprika and sweet paprika.
SPEAKER: Smoked paprika honey.
GAIL SIMMONS: Smoked
paprika honey.
SPEAKER: Locked in.
GAIL SIMMONS: A lot
of different chilies
that you'll see in the book--
aleppo pepper, obviously
chili flakes are a staple.
They come up all
the time because you
can use them in everything.
But Aleppo pepper
and other dried
peppers I really
love cooking with.
Zaatar, which is a spice
blend, I use a lot.
It comes up again
and again in my book
because I'm just so drawn to
those Middle Eastern flavors.
Traditionally zaatar is a spice
blend of sesame and thyme,
sometimes there's
sumac in there.
Sumac is another spice
that actually comes up
again and again in my book.
I put it with chilies and
salt and lime over just
cut up vegetables and fruit.
I use sumac in salad
dressings with tahini,
in Moroccan dishes in addition
to or instead of harissa.
So those are some of the
spices I love the most.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
So our lovely cameraman
is reminding me
that we have to finish
the livestream now.
GAIL SIMMONS: Oh, right.
SPEAKER: We officially say
thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
GAIL SIMMONS: Thank you.
Thanks, [? Jenna. ?]
SPEAKER: So much fun.
GAIL SIMMONS: Of course.